[Música]
muy bienvenidos a directo con 26 el
espacio de france 24 dedicado a
comprender en profundidad qué está
sucediendo en la cumbre climática de la
organización de las naciones unidas que
se lleva a cabo en la ciudad de glasgow
y así se encuentra presente una de
nuestras enviadas especiales hablamos de
marina colorado muy buenos días muy
buenas tardes por allí y marina bueno
hubo importantes anuncios verdad estamos
hablando sobre
anuncios vinculados a la deforestación y
también a las emisiones de metano verdad
así de santiago dos buenas importantes
anuncios salieron hoy de las
declaraciones y de las conferencias de
prensa que hicieron algunos líderes
mundiales la primera se trata de un
acuerdo en el que más de 100 líderes se
comprometieron a reducir y revertir la
deforestación estos líderes forman parte
de países que comprenden el 85 por
ciento de la superficie de bosques del
planeta algunos de estas naciones son a
brasil australia indonesia eeuu reino
unido y república democrática del congo
2 en donde se encuentra la segunda selva
tropical más grande del planeta después
de brasil es son 20 mil millones de
dólares que van a estar dedicados a ese
objetivo de reducir la deforestación y
la degradación de los suelos pero
también hubo un segundo anuncio bastante
importante acerca de la reducción de
emisiones del gas metano un gas que es
80 veces más potente que el de co2 que
el dióxido de carbono pero que se disipa
mucho más rápidamente de la atmósfera lo
cual hace que su reducción pueda
contribuir bastante a que reduzcamos el
calentamiento global de hecho puede
hacer que se reduzca como
2302 la temperatura de aquí a 2030 unos
anuncios bastante importantes pero que
no son vinculantes pero que son por lo
menos buenas noticias para estar
positivos de cosas que salen de la
agenda no oficial de la cob 26 gracias a
marina por tenernos más claridad sobre
estos anuncios tan importantes sobre los
que tuvimos informando durante todas
estas jornadas para más 24 y no está
sola verdad te acompaña a claudia lópez
no ni más ni menos que la alcaldesa de
bogotá a la capital colombiana
si me acompañan a claudia lópez porque
lo que queríamos hablar un poquito es
acerca de todo durante todas las
jornadas de la cob 26 hemos visto como
los gobiernos subnacionales es decir no
los gobiernos elegidos como para
presidencia o jefe de jefatura de estado
sino que los gobiernos de las alcaldías
de los municipios de las regiones de los
estados están siendo mucho más
proactivos en implementar acciones
concretas para luchar contra el cambio
climático y como bien decías me acompaña
claudia lópez ella es la alcaldesa de la
ciudad de bogotá capital de colombia
muchísimas gracias por estar con
nosotros en france 24 en directo con 26
y le quería preguntar
bogotá fue la primera capital del
continente americano en declarar la
emergencia climática por qué es tan
importante hacer esto pero porque la
única manera de liderar en la vida y
liderar con el ejemplo y nosotros
declaramos la emergencia climática por
un acuerdo es ciudadano por un decreto
de la alcaldía y además fue propuesto
por una de las fuerzas de oposición a la
actual alcaldía para demostrar que el
cambio climático tiene que tener un
compromiso que aquí hay no hay
diferencias ideológicas ni políticas
es un compromiso como humanidad por eso
nos enorgullece no solamente haber
declarado la emergencia climática por
acuerdo del consejo de nuestra ciudad
sino además que ese mismo acuerdo fija
metas e inversiones específicas que debe
hacer la ciudad para reducir la mitad de
sus emisiones que vienen del transporte
público y otras de sus emisiones que
vienen por la deforestación por el
inadecuado manejo de los residuos
sólidos y también por las normas de
construcción y usted está aquí también
como representante de cc 40 una
coalición de ciudades contra el cambio
climático cuéntenos acerca de algunos de
los anuncios brevemente le pido que se
están dando en esta con 26 pues como lo
decía es la verdad es que los gobiernos
locales somos los que interactuamos con
la gente los que prestamos servicios los
que sabemos cómo construir coaliciones
desde lo local hablamos menos pero
hacemos más y por eso no está con 26 por
primera vez el grupo de liderazgo de
ciudades contra el cambio climático se
40 unió a mil 49 ciudades del mundo que
tenemos ya un plan de acción climática
financiado y con metas concretas para
nuestras propias ciudades
330 de esa ciudad son de américa latina
y 15 de ellas de colombia tenemos un
plan de acción climática un plan de
emergencia climática como en el caso de
bogotá tenemos financiación de las
ciudades y lo que venimos a decir es que
nosotros hablamos menos hacemos más y
que esperamos que las corporaciones
privadas y los gobiernos nacionales
cumplan su parte de la tarea para evitar
el desastre climático que afronta la
humanidad pues muchísimas gracias
claudia lópez alcaldesa de bogotá y
hasta aquí directo con 26 seguimos en el
estudio muchísimas gracias marina y por
supuesto gracias también a claudia lópez
alcaldesa de bogotá esto fue con 26 en
france 24 sigan informando en el resto
de nuestra programación y en france24
punto com
[Música]